[Musique]
avec Christopher qui est dans le
fauteuil et violet qui est enceinte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en écoutant ACDC on va le croire cette
image résume toute la fête cette affaire
qui a fait tant parler ce weekend qui a
encore fait vivre toutes les chaînes
donc merci à eux parce que tout le
week-end c'est incroyable c'est la
première fois que je suis en bandeau sur
une chaîne
mon frère sur la chaîne à toute
puissance danuna qui pense pouvoir
insulter et intimider une personne parce
qu'elle critique son patron et
inadmissible qu'on soit député ou non un
présentateur n'a pas à insulter
quelqu'un en direct pour avoir critiqué
le propriétaire de sa chaîne c'est un
Punité et les méthodes qui vont avec
doivent cesser c'est pour cette raison
que j'ai décidé de porter plainte mais
cette affaire n'a rien de personnel elle
est avant tout politique le plus gros
reproche que je peux faire à Louis
Brogniart je dis c'est qui vous a Bernez
que lui il a été faux moi j'étais vrai
lui était fou ce qu'il avait tout
prémédité et Louis Boyard était venu
dans un seul but faire du buzz quitter
le plateau et s'attaquer à TPMP
s'attaquer au groupe et s'attaquer à
notre actionnaire en s'attaquant à moi
oui vraiment je peux pas me le saquer il
va dégager rapidement du coup là ils
vont te chauffer oui mais t'inquiète de
toute façon je vais rentrer dans leur
jeu mais je crois pas un seul instant
qui vont me dire pitié je suis pas sorti
du vagin de ma mère il y a deux heures
Nicolas Cyril Hanouna nous dit cette
séquence est la preuve que sur TPMP on
peut tout dire alors que ce que dénonce
lui Boyard c'est précisément qu'on lui
ait coupé la parole et qu'il n'est pas
pu aller au bout de son raisonnement va
prendre une camomille mon Louis alors
évidemment c'est un conseil plein de
sollicitudes je vous le dis et c'est
bête que je vais dire dans une guerre
sont toujours les Gentils qui gagnent à
la fin et pour moi oui Boyard et le
méchant il avait tout prémédité oui
Boyard a eu ce qu'il a voulu il a fait
son buzz et là elle est fille je pense
ils sont plus intelligents que lui et je
pense qu'ils vont venir sur le plateau
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est ce qu'on a
fait pour lui ainsi craquer le Garrido
et je pense qu'ils vont venir j'attribue
à note de 10 parce que il y a eu une
ambiance certes mais elle a démarré
vraiment trop tard va t'acheter un
costume alors c'est bien sûr une manière
de discréditer le jeune député insoumis
alors que c'est précisément lui qui est
venu en costume quand l'auteur du tweet
lui à son émission en switcher c'est une
très belle personne à toutes ces très
belles personnes c'est extraordinaire
c'est un monde de très belles personnes
moi
j'ai eu des
[Rires]
bisous
qui n'est pas censé et pour moi ça c'est
la pire des choses c'est un menteur et
je vous dis Isa il sait jouer de vous
c'est jouer le public ne sait pas trompé
d'ailleurs puisqu'il a eu il lui a
demandé de sortir et il était
extrêmement violent sur le plateau et
Louis Boyard n'en sortira pas grandit de
cette affaire et sachez que nous aussi
on va prendre des mesures et on va
attaquer pour ce qu'il a pu dire
diffamation et toute la diffamation
qu'il a eu à notre égard je m'attendais
à avoir de l'émotion
j'en ai pas eu et bien dites donc
je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire pour
avoir de l'émotion alors
[Musique]
daniel lui parle de son salaire chez
nous il lui dit de rembourser bah son
salaire il est simple je veux dire qu'on
m'a touché Louis Boyard s'il veut le
reverser en tout Louis Boyard a touché
plus de 6000 euros est-ce que vous
l'avez ici les Chéries oui Boyard voilà
il était payé voilà tout ça voilà il a
qu'à touché
6784 euros chez nous voilà donc si il
veut les reverser
plus qu'un député c'est plus qu'un
député je suis CPE donc cancer principal
d'éducation et en fait j'ai voulu filmer
les objets les plus insolites que
j'avais confisqué à mes élèves je l'ai
posté toute innocemment et 4 millions de
vues sur snapchat
enfin plus précisément les cellules
cancéreuses c'est à dire que si tu as
des cellules confiées cancérigeuses dont
ton corps ce produit là les tue un
traitement qui serait interdit à la
vente en France ils veulent pas c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant pour eux que
vous ayez à l'hôpital et que vous payez
une blinde la vidéo scandaleuse sur le
fond comme sur la forme cancérigène
a été supprimé depuis par son auteur moi
le français ça fait 14 frères j'ai dû
doudou une chaussure de ski
c'est vrai il y a un gamin qui est venu
avec une chaussure
c'est-à-dire un gilet pare-balle
alors ça ça me fait quand même beaucoup
plus peur est-ce que vous voulez une
immigration en France oui ou non si
c'est 0 % c'est 0 % c'est-à-dire qu'on
fait les migration zéro zéro c'est à
dire que par exemple vous avez par
exemple Neymar ne joue plus au Paris
Saint-Germain pourquoi pas ah bon très
bien pourquoi pas
un pays au monde qui a ce genre de de
règles c'est impossible
ces vidéos de supporters brésilien
espagnol portugais ou allemand au Qatar
une semaine avant le début de la Coupe
du monde font beaucoup parler car de
nombreux internautes doutent de la
nationalité de ses fans il ressemble un
peu les Brésiliens les Espagnols c'est
bizarre ça non l'Allemagne ça c'est les
Allemands pour beaucoup il s'agit
d'Indiens ou de Pakistanais nombreux au
Qatar payés pour jouer les supporters et
mettre l'ambiance ce n'est pour le
moment qu'une hypothèse mais c'est une
raison de plus pour certains de boycoter
la compétition jamais volontiers pour
Neymar oui pour les footballeurs oui oui
vous avez raison il faudra une exception
et le football